This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. And this is 99PI producer, Lasha Madon. Hi, I'm Lasha. And this is Babushka. I bought this from a shop. Trust me, she's about to be your favorite Russian grandma. If there's one thing you need to know about Babushka, it's this. If you exist in her orbit, she will make sure you are fed. Even if you show up at her home unannounced, Babushka will find a way to assemble a table
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。这位是99PI的制作人拉沙·马顿。大家好，我是拉沙。这位是巴布什卡。这是我从店里买的。相信我，她马上就会成为你最喜欢的俄罗斯奶奶。关于巴布什卡，你只需要知道一件事，那就是：只要你在她的势力范围内，她就一定会确保你吃饱。哪怕你毫无预兆地突然造访她的家，巴布什卡也会设法摆出一桌
full of offerings, because like many immigrants at the former Soviet Union, her small apartment is brimming with enough food and supplies to last month, you know, just in case. Babushka's full name is Yelena Shulir, and she is the grandmother of my partner, Mark. At 83, she's got this boisterous laugh, and she's unwavering in her love for bread, though technically it's been years since her doctor has allowed her to eat any. What kind of foods did you grow up eating? Like, what kind of meals do you remember eating? I had born in 1938. In 1941, start second war. Yeah.
盛宴。因为和前苏联的许多移民一样，她的小公寓里塞满了足够吃上几个月的食物和物资，你知道的，以防万一。巴布什卡的全名是叶连娜·舒利尔，她是我伴侣马克的奶奶。83岁的她有着爽朗的笑声，而且对面包有着坚定不移的爱，尽管严格来说，她的医生已经多年不允许她吃面包了。你从小到大都吃过什么食物？比如，你还记得吃过哪些饭菜？我1938年出生。1941年，第二次世界大战爆发。是的。
And we leave Ukraine, we go to Kazakhstan, like refugee. They could only grow one thing in that dry Kazakh soil. Melans. For a time, melans were published as only source for anything sweet. They don't have nothing. We don't have nothing. I don't see sugar.
我们离开乌克兰，作为难民去了哈萨克斯坦。在那片干燥的哈萨克斯坦土地上，他们只能种一种东西：甜瓜。有一段时间，甜瓜被称为唯一含糖的东西。他们什么都没有。我们什么都没有。我看不到糖。
It's very bad time. It's very, very bad time. Babushka doesn't consider herself much of a cook, but she's always sharing her recipes with me aloud. While we're in a car, on a walk at the table, she tells me how many hours to boil beef tongue before pulling it off the stove, the answer is three. Her how she makes her farmers cheese, and the honey cake recipe she learned from
那是很糟糕的一段时期。那是非常非常糟糕的一段时期。巴布什卡并不觉得自己是个多好的厨师，但她总是大声跟我分享她的食谱。当我们坐在车里、散步时、在餐桌旁，她会告诉我牛舌在出锅前需要煮几个小时，答案是三个。还有她是如何制作农家干酪的，以及她从妈妈那里学来的
her mom. Over the years, crossing the Bay Bridge to visit Babushka in San Francisco has become a kind of ritual, and food is always central, if we weren't meeting over a meal at the very least, we were talking about one. When the pandemic arrived, and we had to put those shared meals on pause, Mark and I wanted to try making Russian food ourselves. So one day, Babushka sent us off with a book, a cookbook, one that she pulled off a shelf where it sat untouched
蜂蜜蛋糕食谱。这些年来，穿过海湾大桥去旧金山看望巴布什卡已经成了一种仪式，而食物始终是核心。如果我们不是聚在一起吃饭，那我们在讨论的至少也是一种食物。当疫情来临，我们不得不暂停那些聚餐时，马克和我决定尝试自己做俄罗斯菜。于是有一天，巴布什卡送了我们一本书，一本食谱，一本她从书架上抽下来的书，那本书在书架上放了多年，
for years. It was heavy like a textbook, a teal colored hardcover. It was one of the oldest books in her possession, literally falling apart at the seams, but stunning at the same time. As an adult, Babushka tells me, she moved to Moscow and got married. And that's when this book came into her life.
一直无人问津。它厚得像一本教科书，有着青绿色的精装封面。这是她拥有的最古老的书之一，书脊实际上已经散架了，但同时又惊艳无比。巴布什卡告诉我，成年后她搬到了莫斯科并结了婚。也就是在那时，这本书进入了她的生活。
It was a wedding gift. Officially titled, The Book of Tasty and Healthy married. And that's when this book came into her life. It was a wedding gift. Officially titled The Book of Tasty and Healthy Food, it was simply known as Kaniga, the book, because it was one of the only cookbooks to exist in the Soviet Union. Babushka, do you remember the last time you opened the book of Tasty and Healthy Food before giving it to us?
那是结婚礼物。官方书名叫作《美味健康结婚。也就是在那时，这本书进入了她的生活。那是结婚礼物。官方书名叫作《美味健康食谱》，它被简称为“卡尼加”，也就是“这本书”，因为它是苏联仅有的几本食谱之一。巴布什卡，你还记得把《美味健康食谱》给我们之前，你最后一次打开它是什么时候吗？
Like, had it been years? years? I love that laugh. No, I don't remember. Okay, so who's that? Oh, that's Mark. He's translating in the background. I don't know. One tells a period one time, I had no idea how to cook them, so I crawled into the book to figure out how to cook them.
比如，是不是已经过去好多年了？多年？我喜欢那个笑声。不，我不记得了。好吧，那是谁？哦，那是马克。他在后台翻译。我不知道。有一次，我完全不知道怎么做那些东西，于是我翻看这本书来琢磨怎么做。
You know how to cook them, but I don't. In Moscow, Babushka had been a librarian. She'd amassed an enormous quantity of books. And when she finally fled the Soviet Union as a Jewish refugee, she had to leave boxes of those books behind. And yet, here's a book she chose to bring with her, one that she's rarely ever used. The book of tasty and healthy food is peppered with glossy photographs of really lavish-looking spreads, and it's dense with text. There are recipes for lentils and crab salad and had a cookbook eat nine different ways. But this book was meant to do so much more than show
你知道怎么做，但我不知道。在莫斯科，巴布什卡曾是一名图书管理员。她收藏了大量的书籍。当她最终作为犹太难民逃离苏联时，她不得不留下好几箱这样的书。然而，这是她选择带在身边的书，一本她几乎从未翻阅过的书。这本《美味健康食谱》里点缀着许多看上去极其奢华的菜肴的光鲜照片，文字也非常密集。里面有扁豆、蟹肉沙拉的食谱，还有教你用九种不同方法吃一本食谱的秘诀。但这本书的意义远不止于向
people how to make certain dishes. It turns out this was the cookbook of the Soviet Union. For decades, a Stalinist document that was created to address one of the most fundamental problems of the USSR. Hunter. And the book was at the vanguard of a radical Soviet food experiment that, despite its numerous obstacles, transformed Russian cuisine. Today, what's usually served in Russian homes and restaurants is Soviet food, food that's generously dolloped with ingredients like mayonnaise and dill.
人们展示如何制作某些菜肴。事实证明，这是苏联的食谱。几十年来，这是一份斯大林主义的文件，旨在解决苏联最根本的问题之一：饥饿。这本书是一场激进的苏联食物实验的先锋，尽管遇到了重重障碍，但它改变了俄罗斯菜肴。今天，俄罗斯家庭和餐馆里通常供应的是苏联食物，这种食物大方地拌入蛋黄酱和莳萝等配料。
But Russian food before the Soviet Union, that was another story. Well, it's dependent on where you fit into Russian society. Edward Geist is a historian who studies the Soviet Union. What people of different classes ate in pre-revolutionary Russia differed enormously. The Russian diet also varied a ton, because the Russian Empire was so large. You don't expect, you know, people living in the Siberian Arctic to eat the same thing, as you know, as like someone in Odessa or someone in the Caucasus. Zara's Russia had both extreme poverty and extreme opulence. Most of the population though, like 95% was living on the edge, on a very basic diet. The basic Russian diet
但在苏联成立之前的俄罗斯菜，那是另一个故事了。嗯，这取决于你在俄罗斯社会中的阶层。爱德华·盖斯特是一位研究苏联的历史学家。在前革命时期的俄罗斯，不同阶层的人吃的东西大不相同。俄罗斯人的饮食也有很大差异，因为俄罗斯帝国太大了。你不会期望生活在西伯利亚北极地区的人，吃的东西会和敖德萨或高加索地区的人一样。沙皇俄国既有极端的贫困，也有极端的富裕。不过，大多数人（大约95%）都在温饱线上挣扎，饮食非常基础。基本的俄罗斯饮食
consisted of a lot of fermented foods. The Russians really love the taste of sour. Derer Goldstein is a food scholar. She's been tracing the evolution of Russian food since the 10th century. There were all kinds of mushrooms and berries that they faraged wonderful dairy products and cabbage soup. So that's basically what they ate and it was pretty monotonous, but it wasn't horrible in terms of nutritive value. It's just that they often didn't have enough and didn't even have enough bread if the harvest was bad. The aristocracy, on the other hand, are fabulously wealthy.
包含大量发酵食物。俄罗斯人真的很喜欢酸味。德雷尔·戈尔斯坦是一位食物学者。她一直在追溯自10世纪以来俄罗斯食物的演变。那里有各种各样的蘑菇和浆果，他们靠采集为生，还有极棒的乳制品和卷心菜汤。所以这基本上就是他们吃的东西，虽然相当单调，但从营养价值上来说并不算太糟糕。只是他们经常吃不饱，如果收成不好，甚至连面包都不够。另一方面，贵族们则富得流油。
It's like enormous quantities of caviar, but there'd be things like, we have this borscht, this borscht that literally has like 30 or 40 different ingredients in it, like seven different kinds of meat. And for a couple hundred years, that's how it went. Most Russians were subsisting off the land, and when the crops would fail, which they did with some regularity, things would get dire. In a way, the problem of food superseded all other problems in Russia. During World War I, food riots broke out between merchants and peasants because of high prices and food shortages. These battles largely overgrain and sugar, kept resurfacing.
比如大量的鱼子酱，还有各种菜肴，比如我们吃的这种罗宋汤，里面字面上有30或40种不同的食材，比如七种不同的肉。在几百年里，情况一直如此。大多数俄罗斯人靠土地维系生计，而当庄稼歉收时（这是常有的事），情况就会变得糟糕。在某种程度上，食物问题压倒了俄罗斯的所有其他问题。第一次世界大战期间，由于高昂的价格和粮食短缺，商人与农民之间爆发了粮食骚乱。这些主要围绕谷物和糖的争端不断死灰复燃。
And then in 1917, revolution swept through Russia, and it gave way to a grand new country. The USSR. Picture a region encompassing 11 time zones, 15 republics, a sixth of the world's landmass. This was the Soviet Union, and in the spirit of uniting all its disparate parts under socialism, its plan was this, we will share one constitution, one national anthem, and one cuisine. New foods, it was decided, were needed to help define the new empire. All ties to aristocracy needed to be broken.
然后在1917年，革命席卷了俄罗斯，催生了一个伟大崭新的国家：苏联。想象一个横跨11个时区、包含15个加盟共和国、占据世界陆地面积六分之一的地区。这就是苏联，本着将所有分散部分在社会主义下团结起来的精神，它的计划是这样的：我们将共享一部宪法、一首国歌和一种饮食。人们决定，需要新的食物来帮助定义这个新的帝国。必须打破与贵族阶层的所有联系。
This was a revolution after all. Under Lenin, who was Soviet Russia's first leader, the Bolsheviks were looking for a way to feed everybody, separate themselves from decadence, and embrace the modern era. No more foraging for berries or mushrooms from the forest, no more following grandma's recipes are cooking from scratch. All of that, dear comrades, was a waste of time. The now-old-fashioned Russian food was declared ideologically unfit.
这毕竟是一场革命。在苏联第一位领导人列宁的领导下，布尔什维克正在寻找一种方法来养活所有人，让自己与颓废划清界限，并拥抱现代时代。不再去森林里寻找浆果或蘑菇，不再遵循奶奶的食谱或从头开始烹饪。亲爱的同志们，所有这一切都是在浪费时间。现在已经过时的俄罗斯食物被宣布在意识形态上不合格。
It was clear that something about food needed to change, but there was no blueprint to get there. No one had ever prescribed what a communist revolution should taste like. There wasn't some passage in marks that said Buckwheat is meant to be the food of the socialist future. Lenin had tried setting up state-run canteens, A place where workers could fuel up with the appropriate amount of calories. But the canteens were run by amateur cooks who churned out terrible food. In the mid-1920s, Lenin died. Stalin came to power, and the Soviet Union
显然，关于食物的某些方面需要改变，但并没有实现这一目标的蓝图。从来没有人规定过共产主义革命应该是什么味道。马克思的著作中并没有这样的段落：荞麦注定是社会主义未来的食物。列宁曾试图建立国营食堂，供工人们补充适量的卡路里。但这些食堂由业余厨师经营，做出的食物非常糟糕。20世纪20年代中期，列宁逝世。斯大林上台，而苏联
was still a starving country. With the chaos of Stalin's forced collectivization policies, he starved the countryside to feed the cities. At times, organized teams of policemen would break into peasant households, taking everything edible. All this led to a major Soviet famine, which killed at least 5 million people, mostly across Ukraine and Kazakhstan. Hungry peasants roamed the countryside, desperately searching for anything to eat.
仍然是一个饥荒肆虐的国家。随着斯大林强制集体化政策带来的混乱，他通过让农村挨饿来养活城市。有时，有组织的警察队伍会闯入农民家中，拿走所有能吃的东西。这一切导致了一场空前的苏联大饥荒，夺去了至少500万人的生命，主要集中在乌克兰和哈萨克斯坦。饥饿的农民在乡村四处流浪，绝望地寻找任何可以吃的东西。
Corpses piled up along the roads. It became clear that Stalin's policies were pushing the country deeper into crisis. He desperately needed to turn things around. Lenin had promised the people the basics, land, peace, and bread. But Stalin decided bread wasn't enough. People needed to feel like they had a sense of luxury in their lives. They needed a reason to still believe in the Soviet Union. There was a sense that the country was exhausted, that the country made huge sacrifices, and Stalin sort of reintroduced some of the bourgeois values. Ania von Bremzen is a food writer who was born in Soviet Russia. It was understood that people needed some kind of relief and reprieve and that the Soviet
道路两旁尸横遍野。很明显，斯大林的政策正在把国家推向更深的危机。他迫切需要扭转局面。列宁曾向人民承诺最基础的东西：土地、和平和面包。但斯大林决定面包还不够。人们需要感受到他们的生活中有一种奢侈感。他们需要一个继续信仰苏联的理由。人们普遍感到国家已经精疲力竭，国家做出了巨大的牺牲，于是斯大林重新引入了一些资产阶级价值观。安妮亚·冯·布姆岑是一位出生于苏俄的美食作家。人们明白，需要某种救济和喘息机会，而且苏联
food industry needed to get its shit together and give something to the people. The revolution was still young, the country in crisis, and Stalin was desperate to get the people symbols of joy. And so just a few years after that disastrous famine, Stalin was like, forget bread, people need champagne and chocolate and caviar. In this campaign to make life nor joyous, which is literally what Stalin said in a 1935 speech. He made it allowable to indulge. So part of your responsibility as a good Soviet citizen to build a perfect socialist state was to participate in the good life too.
食品工业需要振作起来，给人民一些东西。革命尚在初期，国家陷入危机，斯大林迫切希望给人民带来快乐的象征。因此，在那场灾难性的大饥荒几年后，斯大林的态度就像是：忘掉面包吧，人们需要香槟、巧克力和鱼子酱。在这场让生活变得更快乐的运动中（这正是斯大林在1935年的一次演讲中所说的），他允许人们纵情享受。因此，作为一名优秀的苏联公民，建设完美社会主义国家的部分责任，也包括参与美好生活。
And in his quest to create this joyous and indulgent Soviet diet, Stalin decided to enlist the help of a guy named Anastas Mikhayan. Anastas Mikhyan is one of the most fascinating figures of the Soviet epic because he came to power as one of Stalin's guys. In the mid-30s, Stalin made Mikhail, the people's commissar of the food industry. So, the Soviet food industry is basically set up according to what Mikhail felt that it should be like. Mikhail was a mustachioid Armenian.
为了创造这种快乐且纵容的苏联饮食，斯大林决定争取一个名叫阿纳astas·米高扬的人的帮助。阿纳astas·米高扬是苏联时代最迷人的人物之一，因为他是作为斯大林的心腹之一上台的。30年代中期，斯大林任命米高扬为食品工业人民委员。因此，苏联食品工业基本上是按照米高扬认为应该有的样子建立起来的。米高扬是个留着八字胡的亚美尼亚人。
He eventually became one of the most significant statesmen in the Soviet Union. He somehow survived decades of purchase, always managing to stay on the good side of whoever was in power. He was a pragmatist, but also a dreamer. And he loved food. Stalin tasked him with a seemingly insurmountable problem, Figure out how to feed a starving country and keep the food riots at bay. And ultimately, unite the Soviet block under a new and happy cuisine. To Mikhail, the solution was clear. His new cuisine would be cheap, high calorie,
他最终成为了苏联最重要的政治家之一。他不知怎么在几十年的清洗中存活了下来，总能保持在当权者的好感名单上。他是一个现实主义者，但也是一个梦想家。他热爱食物。斯大林给他的任务是一个看似不可逾越的难题：想办法养活一个饥饿的国家，并遏制粮食骚乱。最终，在一种全新且快乐的饮食下团结苏联阵营。对米高扬来说，解决方案很明确。他的新饮食将是廉价的、高热量的、
mass distributed, and prepackaged. And for that, naturally, he turned to the most unsoviet place imaginable. A place that caters to the need for instant gratification, better than anywhere else in the world. The US of A. Well, what do they eat in America? They eat a lot of meat. They eat things like, you know, hot dogs and hamburgs. You know, they have a processed breakfast series, like they have all of this sort of industrial produced, convenient sort of core, dense food. It turns out American food, and specifically its innovations in mass production at the time, checked a lot of boxes for Mikoyan as he looked to make over the Soviet diet. At the time, most of Russia's food production was small scale and artisanal.
大规模分销的、预包装的。为此，他自然而然地转向了你能想象到的最不苏联的地方。一个比世界上任何地方都更能迎合即时满足需求的地方：美利坚合众国。嗯，他们在美国吃什么？他们吃很多肉。他们吃诸如热狗和汉堡之类的主食。你知道，他们有加工早餐系列，他们拥有所有这种工业化生产、方便快捷的、核心且高热量的食物。事实证明，美国食物，特别是它当时在大规模生产方面的创新，在米高扬试图改造苏联饮食时满足了很多条件。当时，俄罗斯的大部分食品生产规模都很小，属于手工作坊性质。
It wasn't scalable in a way that could feed the whole country. Mikiyawn was interested in the factory lines that were feeding the workers in America. The idea being, it's not capitalism we're interested in. It's modernity. We can import these American products and machines and turn them socialist. It's socialist because it's being made in like a state-owned factory.
它的规模无法扩大到养活整个全国的水平。米高扬对那些养活美国工人的工厂流水线很感兴趣。其核心理念是：我们感兴趣的不是资本主义，而是现代性。我们可以进口这些美国产品和机器，然后把它们变成社会主义的。之所以是社会主义的，是因为它们是在国营工厂里制造的。
The fact that it looks exactly like the American original that we copied it from, it's like, well, that just makes it modern. And so, in 1936, Stalin sent Mikhail to the U.S. He gave his food commissar a mission to scour America for the secrets of capitalist food manufacturing. On an August morning, he and his wife landed in New York, and from there, they toured 12,000 miles across the country. Officially, Mikiyawn was tasked with buying industrial equipment for the Soviet food industry, but he got a little carried away.
它看起来跟我们抄袭的美国原版一模一样，这只能说明它很现代。因此，在1936年，斯大林把米高扬派往美国。他给他的食品委员下达了一个任务：在全美搜寻资本主义食品制造的秘密。在一个八月的早晨，他和妻子在纽约登陆，从那里开始，他们在全国各地巡视了12,000英里。官方上，米高扬的任务是为苏联食品工业采购工业设备，但他有点乐不思蜀了。
Mikiya quickly became fascinated by things like orange juice and frozen fruit. He visited canning factories and slaughterhouses. He studied metal jarlets and corrugated cardboard. As he toured the country, Mikiyaan inspected every aspect of the production line. His memoirs are full of awe for the things he ate, like hamburgers. Mikiyaan wrote, for a he ate, like hamburgers. Mikhail wrote, for a busy man, it is very convenient. In the burger, he saw a cheap and filling snack, great for workers on the go.
米高扬很快就被诸如橙汁和冷冻水果之类的事物迷住了。他参观了罐头厂和屠宰场。他研究了金属罐头和瓦楞纸板。在全国巡回期间，米高扬视察了生产线的方方面面。他的回忆录里充满了对自己吃过的事物（如汉堡包）的惊叹。米高扬写道，对于一个忙碌的人来说，汉堡非常方便。他在汉堡中看到了一个廉价又顶饱的快餐，非常适合行色匆匆的工人。
Mikhail can picture it all in his head. Here were some of the foundations of what would become Soviet cuisine, a plan to feed the masses, a way to save the USSR from its food crisis. Mikayan came back to the Soviet Union and started to build. His hamburger factories were built to turn out 2 million patties a day. And within a year Mikayan's meat plant, called Mikayanovsky, produced over 100 kinds of sausages. He oversaw the production of canned fish and corn and peas, cheeses and meats, juices and popcorn, corn flakes and champagne.
米高扬在脑海中勾勒出了这一切。这些正是将要成为苏联饮食的基础：一个养活大众的计划，一个将苏联从食品危机中拯救出来的方法。米高扬回到苏联后便开始大兴土木。他的汉堡工厂建立起来，每天生产200万个汉堡肉饼。一年之内，米高扬名为“米高扬夫斯基”的肉类加工厂生产了100多种香肠。他监督生产了罐头鱼、玉米、豌豆、奶酪、肉类、果汁、爆米花、玉米片和香槟。
I could go on. And of course, a high calorie condiment that could go in every salad. Mayonnaise. And it's been made the same way since the 30s. You know, it's like it's basically the Russian equivalent of hell. It's like this is classic, Soviet thing. Right, everyone knows the bottles. Right. And so when Russians are, like,
我还可以继续列举。当然，还有一种高热量的调味品，可以加进每一道沙拉里：蛋黄酱。它的制作方法自30年代以来就一直没变。你知道，它基本上就是俄罗斯版的“地狱”牌酱料。就像这是经典的苏联事物。没错，大家都知道那些瓶子。没错。所以当俄罗斯人，比如说，
when they think mayonnaise, well, that's kind of their platonic ideal mayonnaise at most of them have, is this stuff that's actually like a formula that Mickey Gond supposedly personally approved because when he was, like, commissar of the food industry, it's like that was one of the things that he did. He had to sign the, you know,
当他们想起蛋黄酱时，嗯，那可以说是他们大多数人心目中完美的蛋黄酱原型，其实就是一种据说由米高扬本人亲自批准的配方，因为当他担任食品工业委员时，那正是他所做的事情之一。他必须签署每一款大规模生产食物的，
the official Soviet, you know, recipe for every kind of, uh, of mass produced a food. Through it all, Mikhail was a dogged micromanager. He tasted every new product, approved every last label design, and he named a lot of the products after himself. To many Russians, Mikhail was just a brand name for the meat products he developed. He was like some mythical old uncle, a Soviet chef boy, RD. Behind the scenes though,
官方苏联式配方。整个过程中，米高扬都是一个固执的微观管理者。他品尝每一款新产品，批准每一个标签设计的细节，并且以自己的名字命名了许多产品。对许多俄罗斯人来说，米高扬只是他所开发的肉类产品的一个品牌名称。他就像某种神话中的老叔叔，堪称苏联版的“贝蒂妙厨”（Chef Boyardee）。不过在幕后，
Mikhail was turning out product after product. And since the average Russian rarely left the country, it required special permission from the state to leave. A lot of people had never before seen some of the foods he was mass producing. When things like oranges and hard cheeses and cornflakes arrived, some found it weird or just confusing. There were certain cases where people really just didn't know what to do with some of this stuff.
米高扬源源不断地推出各种产品。由于普通俄罗斯人很少离开国家，离境需要获得国家的特许。许多人以前从未见过他批量生产的一些食物。当橙子、硬干酪和玉米片等东西运到时，有些人觉得很怪异，甚至一头雾水。在某些情况下，人们真的不知道该如何处理这些东西。
Because it was not the sort of thing that Russians said typically seen before. As these weird new foods started to spread, Mikhail found himself touring villages to give food directives. He urged Soviets to embrace a spicy aromatic condiment that he said every American housewife keeps in her cupboard. Ketchup. He proclaimed tomato juice as the Soviet national drink. He advised people who had never heard of corn flakes
因为这不是俄罗斯人平时见过的东西。随着这些奇怪的新食物开始传播，米高扬发现自己不得不去各个村庄发布食品指令。他敦促苏联人接受一种辛辣芳香的调味品，并称每个美国主妇的碗橱里都备有这种东西：番茄酱。他宣布番茄酱是苏联的国饮。他建议那些从未听说过玉米片的人，
to try putting them in their soup like crackers. He gave how-t's on eating oranges. And so like to get an orange, and they try and just bite into it with a peel on it. Of course, it tastes disgusting because they're eating the peel. And they had to be told that it's like, well, there's supposed to peel it first.
尝试把它像饼干一样泡在汤里吃。他还传授了吃橙子的方法。比如要想吃个橙子，他们会试图连皮直接咬下去。当然，这味道糟透了，因为他们在吃皮。人们不得不被告知，其实他们应该先剥皮。
Mikaion realized people needed to know about these foods in order to be willing to eat them. They needed to become cultured Soviet citizens. And despite all his travels telling people what to eat and how, it was impossible for him to educate everyone. He needed a new way to reach the masses. How could he spread a single new food culture to over 150 million people? And so in 1939, he decided to publish a book. The book of Tasty and Healthy Food, the one that landed in my lap by way of Babushka. This book became the official blueprint on how to eat Soviet food.
米高扬意识到，人们需要了解这些食物，才愿意去吃它们。他们需要成为有文化素养的苏联公民。尽管他到处奔波，告诉人们吃什么、怎么吃，但他不可能教育到每一个人。他需要一种新方法来触及大众。他如何将一种全新的饮食文化传播给1.5亿多人口？于是，在1939年，他决定出版一本书。《美味健康食谱》，也就是经由巴布什卡传到我手里的那一本。这本书成了关于如何吃苏联食物的官方蓝图。
Written by a team of food scientists and spearheaded by Mikkayan, the book provides nutritional guidelines, advertisements for prepackaged foods, and hundreds of recipes. And the Soviet state cranked out millions and millions of copies. How many copies of the book do you have? Looking at my shelf, I have just one, two, three, four, five. In total, the book has over 1,400 recipes spanning 400 pages. It also has descriptions of Mikaian's industrial progress and advice on things like proper food storage and table manners.
这本书由一个食品科学家团队编写，由米高扬牵头，提供了营养指南、预包装食品广告以及数百种食谱。苏联政府印制了数以千万计的副本。你家里有多少本这本书？看看我的书架，我只有一本、两本、三本、四本、五本。总的来说，这本书包含1,400多道食谱，跨越400页。它还描述了米高扬的工业化进展，并就正确的食物储存和餐桌礼仪等方面提出了建议。
And the side bars will contain all sorts of descriptions, often just descriptions of all these interesting new industrial food products that the Soviet Union is producing. On each page, banners above or below the recipes celebrate Mikaian's products, like Soviet soy sauce and frozen pigmeiny. And in the side bars are descriptions of industrial progress, like the various attempts to grow pineapples in the USSR. The book offers aesthetic tips, too.
侧边栏里包含了各种各样的描述，通常只是对苏联正在生产的所有这些有趣的新工业食品的描述。在每一页上，食谱上方或下方的横幅都在庆祝米高扬的产品，比如苏联酱油和冷冻饺子。侧边栏则是对工业进展的描述，例如在苏联种植菠萝的各种尝试。这本书还提供了审美建议。
Each dish should be delicious and have visual appeal it reads and the images of course are gorgeous. The first thing that struck me were just the photographs which are fantastic. I mean fantastic in both senses of the word. The inside cover shows tables crowded with silver and crystal, platters of bread and fruit, boxes of chocolates and trays of caviar nestled between intricate teacets and slices of cake. A whole suckling pig sits in the center. It represented all the luxury that Stalin had envisioned. They have this vintage look to them, beautiful colors,
每道菜都应该美味且具有视觉吸引力，书中写道，而图片当然美轮美奂。首先吸引我的是照片，它们太棒了。我是说，这个词在双重意义上都棒极了。内封面展示了挤满银器和水晶的桌子、一盘盘的面包和水果、一盒盒的巧克力以及镶嵌在精致茶具和蛋糕切片之间的鱼子酱托盘。中央摆着一整只烤乳猪。它代表了斯大林所设想的一切奢华。它们有一种复古的外观，美丽的色彩，
and conveying this sense of abundance. That was the primary thing, like endless food, endless variety. The book incorporated dishes from across the Soviet republics, Plough from Uzbekistan, Borsh from Ukraine, although the origins of these foods were not always disclosed. Mikhail was showing that we are all Soviet and hey, any simple worker or teacher or doctor can now buy a bottle of champagne or cook a lobster in white wine sauce as shown on page 144.
并传达出一种富足感。这是最主要的一点，仿佛食物无穷无尽，品种应有尽有。这本书收录了来自苏联各加盟共和国的菜肴，乌兹别克斯坦的抓饭、乌克兰的罗宋汤，尽管这些食物的起源并不总是被公开。米高扬在向世人展示：我们全都是苏联人，瞧，任何一个普通的工人、教师或医生现在都可以买一瓶香槟，或者像第144页所示的那样，用白葡萄酒酱烹调一只龙虾。
Life is good. Over the years, the book kept getting revised and republished to match the Soviet Union's changing ideologies. All specific references to a dish being Jewish or American, for example, eventually disappeared. But throughout all the editions, one thing was constant. The book evoked a peculiar optimism. It took on an almost aggressive cheeriness. And by the 1950s, it became a staple in people's homes. On Yvonne Bremsen has studied a lot of cookbooks that have come out of dictatorships, from the Frankoist regime in Spain to fascist Italy. She says, there is just nothing else like the book.
生活很美好。多年来，这本书不断被修订和再版，以配合苏联不断变化的意识形态。例如，所有关于某道菜是犹太菜或美国菜的具体表述最终都消失了。但在所有版本中，有一点是不变的：这本书唤起了一种奇特的乐观主义。它带有几乎具有侵略性的欢快感。到了20世纪50年代，它成了人们家中的必备品。安妮亚·冯·布姆岑研究过许多来自独裁统治下的食谱，从西班牙的佛朗哥政权到法西斯意大利。她说，世上再无其他书籍能与之相比。
It was aware of a culture rating people who previously didn't have access to anything, like, you know, let's say peasants or workers, to become cultured Soviet citizens who knew how to use the right fork. It's kind of just this amazing, amazing document. With the help of this book, at first gradually, but then faster and faster, Mikhail's foods became Russian foods. But what's interesting is that they were very patrioticly packaged to generations of Russians this was awful. So for me to read it and to learn this, oh my god, you know, you look at American, you basically copy the American, or you know, Frankfurters, Russian love Frankfurters, Saisiski,
它肩负着一种文化启蒙的使命，教导那些以前接触不到任何东西的人（比如农民或工人）成为懂得如何正确使用叉子的有教养的苏联公民。这简直是一份惊人的、惊人的文献。在这本书的帮助下，起初是逐渐地，然后是越来越快地，米高扬的食物变成了俄罗斯食物。但有趣的是，它们被以极具爱国主义色彩的方式包装了起来，对几代俄罗斯人来说，这简直太糟糕了。所以对我来说，当我阅读并了解到这一点时，天哪，你会发现美国人……你基本上就是抄袭了美国，或者你知道的，法兰克福香肠，俄罗斯人热爱法兰克福香肠、香肠，
that was actually a German recipe. So the origins of so many of this patriotic and beloved items are in fact foreign. Many foods eventually became altered, specified versions of the American food that inspired it. Like those hamburgers Mikaian had encountered with such wonder, they turned into a meat and bread patty called cutliette, which became a Soviet staple. The book features multiple recipes on how to make it, and it's a dish that's still super popular today. But there was one dish that really took off,
这其实是一个德国食谱。因此，这么多爱国且备受喜爱的食物，其起源实际上是外来的。许多食物最终变成了对其提供灵感的美国食物的改良、特定版本。就像米高扬曾惊叹遇见的那些汉堡包一样，它们变成了一种名为“肉饼”（cutliette）的肉加面包的饼，并成为了苏联的主食。这本书刊登了多种制作它的食谱，至今仍是一道超级受欢迎的菜肴。但有一道菜真正风靡开来，
maybe more than any other. It's all the way at the back of the book. You have to flip past the soups and meat dishes until you reach the desserts. Ice cream. It was the ultimate success of the Soviet food project. Our ice cream was the best ice cream. We were always told that.
也许比任何其他菜都要流行。它在书的最末尾。你必须翻过汤品和肉类菜肴，直到到达甜点部分：冰淇淋。这是苏联食品工程的终极成功。我们的冰淇淋是最好的冰淇淋。我们从小就被这么告知。
And in fact, it was like really good. Well, the Russian, the aristocratic types, well, they ate ice cream before the revolution, right? But not in any sort of great quantity. At the time, the idea that any Soviet citizen could buy ice cream from someone off the street for a modest price was unheard of. But that changed when Mikhail started mass-producing ice cream in the way he had observed in the
事实上，它确实非常好吃。好吧，俄罗斯那些贵族阶层，他们在革命前也吃冰淇淋，对吧？但数量并不多。当时，任何一个苏联公民都能以不高的价格从街头小贩那里买到冰淇淋，这是闻所未闻的。但这种情况在米高扬开始像他在美国所观察到的那样大规模生产冰淇淋后发生了改变。
US. In fact, he lobbied so hard for it that Stalin once joked that Mikaian must have loved ice cream more than communism. The Soviet Union's first ice cream factory reached a total volume of 46,000 tons of ice cream a year. Under Mikaian's leadership, a completely new culture around ice cream started to form. All ice cream vendors wore special uniforms, white caps,
事实上，他为此极力游说，以至于斯大林曾开玩笑说，米高扬对冰淇淋的爱一定超过了对共产主义的爱。苏联第一家冰淇淋工厂的年总产量达到了46,000吨冰淇淋。在米高扬的领导下，围绕冰淇淋的全新文化开始形成。所有冰淇淋小贩都穿着统一的制服：白色帽子、
aprons, and overcoats. People would go out in the dead of winter and hang around just eating ice cream in their winter jackets. Here's Babushka again. And the rest are cold. It's Babushka again. In Russia cold. It's very very cold. And people go with this ice cream on the street. You can understand this. I can picture it, but it's hard for me to understand.
围裙和大衣。人们甚至会在数九寒冬里走上街头，穿着冬衣四处闲逛，只为了吃冰淇淋。巴布什卡又出场了。外面很冷。又是巴布什卡。俄罗斯很冷。非常非常冷。人们在街上吃这种冰淇淋。你能理解吗？我可以想象，但我很难理解。
Nobody can understand it, but in Russia it's true. Why? Why do you think so? I don't know. I don't know. We like ice cream. The book features a number of different ice cream recipes and details about their nutritional information.
没有人能理解，但在俄罗斯这是真的。为什么？你觉得为什么？我不知道。我不知道。我们就是喜欢冰淇淋。书中收录了许多不同的冰淇淋食谱以及关于其营养成分的详细信息。
And then it goes, in terms of taste and quality, ice cream made by the food industry always surpasses ice cream that is produced at home. As in, here are a handful of recipes, but don't bother trying them. And maybe that was the whole point. The book was a cookbook, yeah, but having people make its recipes wasn't the goal. More so, it was meant to show you what was worth desiring, and that socialism would get you there eventually.
接着书中写道：就口味和质量而言，食品工业生产的冰淇淋总是胜过家制的冰淇淋。意思是：这里有几个食谱，但你们就别费心去尝试了。也许这正是整本书的意义所在。这本书确实是一本食谱，但让人们照着做并不是它的终极目标。更多情况下，它是为了向你展示什么是值得向往的，而社会主义最终会让你实现这一切。
But the truth was much more grim. In fact, most of Babushka's memories are not of lavish spreads and homemade desserts, but of food scarcity. Here's Mark again, translating Bobushka's Russian. Bobushka has always had this impulse to feed others. But when she was a child, it was tough for her mom to watch Bobushka give away food, because they didn't have much at all. Bobushka? She says when she was little, she gets that Kamal would cook her chicken broth.
但真相要残酷得多。事实上，巴布什卡的大部分记忆都不是丰盛的宴席和自制甜点，而是食物的匮乏。马克再次出场，翻译巴布什卡的俄语。巴布什卡一直有一种喂饱别人的冲动。但当她还是个孩子时，看着巴布什卡把食物送人对她妈妈来说是一件很难受的事，因为他们自己根本没有什么食物。巴布什卡？她说是她小时候，她记得妈妈会给她煮鸡汤。
And she was really boys, just outside in the courtyard of the house, wherever in the yard. And she would feed them through the window with her spoons. What? They would just be standing outside your window with their mouth open? Yeah! Come go check it. Just like little baby seagulls. These are funny stories now, but that kind of hunger, Babushka says, it's difficult for us kids to imagine. It's impossible to imagine. I wish for you never to know that, never to see it. It is hard to imagine, especially as I flip through pages of the book. Because even as Mikaian was implementing his cuisine and revising this cookbook, and
她当时还是个小女孩，就在房子的庭院外面，无论是在院子里的什么地方。她会用勺子通过窗户喂那些人。什么？他们就站在你窗外，张着嘴？对！过来看看。就像小海鸥一样。这些现在听起来像是好笑的故事，但巴布什卡说，那种饥饿感是我们这些孩子很难想象的。简直无法想象。我希望你们永远不要经历那种事，永远不要看到它。这确实很难想象，特别是我正翻阅着这本书的页码。因为即使米高扬在推行他的饮食计划并修订这本食谱，而且
certain foods were indeed taking off, his successes were papering over a dark underlying reality. That hunger was still the primary struggle. Because it turns out many of the foods that Mikiyaon's factories were turning out day after day were rarely ever available for purchase. Even though everyone knew about these foods, the grocery shelves were mostly empty. For decades, outside of a handful of stores in the big cities, there weren't many places you could just plunk down your rubles and buy this stuff. Most of the food it turned out had been disappearing into networks of privileged elites long before it even reached the shelves. Everyone tried to befriend a butcher. You'd smile extra hard as you walked in the store. You had to, if you had any hope of getting a good piece of meat or any meat at all.
某些食物确实风靡一时，但他的成功却掩盖了一个黑暗的底层现实：饥饿依然是人们面临的主要挣扎。因为事实证明，米高扬的工厂日复一日生产的许多食物，人们很少能买到。尽管每个人都知道这些食物，但杂货店的货架大多空空如也。几十年来，除了大城市里少数几家商店之外，你很少能在什么地方掏出卢布买到这些东西。事实证明，大部分食物在到达货架之前，就已经消失在特权阶层的关系网中了。每个人都试图和屠夫交朋友。当你走进商店时，你会笑得格外灿烂。如果你想买到一块好肉，哪怕只是能买到一点肉，你也必须这么做。
If you had any hope of getting a good piece of meat, or any meat at all. Yeah, I mean, food was the object of, you know, constant longing, desire, anxiety. It was really pretty much the focus of our lives. Like, you know, I literally had a banana maybe like four times in my life. Because food supply was unpredictable, Anya told me that anytime she left the house, she'd carry a mesh bag crumpled in her pocket. The bag was called a voiceca, which means what if? As in, what if I stumble upon a store with food inside it today?
如果你想买到一块好肉，哪怕只是能买到一点肉的话。是的，我的意思是，食物是人们不断渴望、向往和焦虑的对象。它几乎就是我们生活的全部焦点。比如说，我这辈子可能总共只吃过四次香蕉。由于食物供应无法预测，安妮亚告诉我，她每次出门都会在口袋里揣一个揉成一团的网兜。这个网兜被称为“voiska”，意思是“万一呢？”比如，万一我今天碰巧遇到一家有食物的商店呢？
So there was this kind of chase, the unpredictability, oh, you know, you pass a store and there's a long line for something some people just would get into the line without even asking what it was for. Meanwhile, at home, the book offered salivating images of the kind of food you were supposed to be able to eat. So we looked at those pictures,
所以当时存在着这样一种追逐和不确定性，哦，你知道的，当你路过一家商店，看到外面排着长队时，有些人甚至不会问这是在排什么队，就会直接加入队伍。与此同时，在家里，这本书提供了令人垂涎欲滴的食物图片，让你觉得自己本该吃到这些东西。所以我们看着那些图片，
you know, I think there's one picture of, you know, suckling pig and there's one picture of oysters. And it's kind of like, okay, we've never seen it, we don't know what this is, but it was advertised. Every cookbook sells a fantasy, of course, but it's the discrepancy between the abundance on the pages and the absence in the shops
你知道的，我想其中有一张是烤乳猪的照片，还有一张是生蚝的照片。那种感觉就像是，好吧，我们从来没见过，我们不知道这是什么，但它确实在广告里。当然，每一本食谱都在兜售一种幻想，但正是书页上的丰盛与商店里的空空如也之间的巨大落差，
that makes the book so jarring. The book suggested everyone adopt a four-course lunch, but much of the population would batch cook for the week with whatever few ingredients they had on hand. It's clear who the book was written for. To the Soviet housewife, it reads, in bold-type face on page one. But for many Soviet women, the book often lived on a shelf, somewhere out of reach. lived on a shelf, somewhere out of reach. I can tell you, I don't think I can use it. Maybe it's a good one.
才让这本书显得如此刺耳。这本书建议每个人都采用四道菜的午餐，但大部分民众只能靠手头仅有的那点食材批量烹饪一周的饭菜。这本书是为谁写的，一目了然。第一页用加粗字体写着：“献给苏联主妇”。但对许多苏联女性来说，这本书通常被束之高阁，放在某个够不着的地方。放在某个够不着的地方。我敢说，我觉得我根本用不上它。也许它确实是一本好书。
Back in Babish goes apartment. I wanted to try cooking something from the book together. I was curious how these recipes held up. It's a package. It's good. Yeah, it's really good. First couple are always through the list. Yeah, it's good.
回到巴布什卡的公寓。我想一起尝试用书中的方法做点东西。我很想知道这些食谱经不经得起考验。这是包装好的。挺好。对，真的很好。前两道菜总是从名单开始。对，很好。
Yeah, it's good. First couple are always through the list. Yeah, it's good. Yeah, it's good. Yeah, it's delicious. It's delicious. It's delicious. It's delicious. It's delicious. It's delicious. It's delicious. It's delicious. It's delicious. It's delicious.
对，很好。前两道菜总是从名单开始。对，很好。对，很好。对，太好吃了。太好吃了。太好吃了。太好吃了。太好吃了。太好吃了。太好吃了。太好吃了。太好吃了。太好吃了。
It's delicious. It's delicious. It's delicious. It's delicious. It's delicious. I do consider myself a good cook, but the truth is I was skeptical of how this would turn out. The book's recipes have incredibly vague instructions, instructions like put meat in oven until cooked, then serve. There are no meal preparation times, no serving sizes. The most frequent instruction in the book is to open a tin can of some kind. most frequent instruction in the book is to open a tin can of some kind. As I mixed the batter together, Babushka flipped through the book and I peered over her shoulder. We landed on a couple recipes that caused her to chuckle. Recipes she thinks no one would have followed.
太好吃了。太好吃了。太好吃了。太好吃了。太好吃了。我自认为是个好厨师，但说实话，我对这道菜的成品质感持怀疑态度。书中的食谱说明极其模糊，诸如“将肉放入烤箱直到烤熟，然后上桌”这样的指示。没有任何备餐时间，也没有分量说明。书中出现频率最高的指令是：打开某种罐头。书中出现频率最高的指令是：打开某种罐头。当我搅拌面糊时，巴布什卡翻看着书，我从她肩膀上方望过去。我们翻到了一些让她哑然失笑的食谱。这些食谱是她认为根本不会有人去遵循的。
Meals that called for real crab meat or fresh figs or game birds. It all made me think that this cookbook was useless, but Anya told me the book, despite its flaws, did have its uses. Anya remembers noticing how the copies of the book she saw in other people's homes would be heavily annotated. People would write over the recipes or write in the margins. It became a way of taking the kitchen back, taking something that was produced by the Soviet Union and making it your own. It was almost like this repository of this private knowledge because the book is like very much represents the Soviet state, but people sort of made accommodations with a totalitarian regime by, you know, by personalizing these documents.
需要真正的蟹肉、新鲜无花果或野禽的餐点。这一切让我觉得这本食谱毫无用处，但安妮亚告诉我，这本书尽管有缺点，确实也有它的用处。安妮亚记得，她看到别人家里的书上都有密密麻麻的批注。人们会在食谱上涂改，或者在空白处写字。这成了一种夺回厨房的方式，把一个由苏联生产的东西变成你自己的东西。它几乎就像是一个私人知识的存储库，因为这本书很大程度上代表了苏联国家机器，但人们通过个性化这些文献，某种程度上适应了这个极权政体。
After the Soviet Union collapsed in 91, there was a lot of hunger and anger again. A lot of people lost everything. To many, these foods conjure up nostalgia from that terrible time. In these Soviet food brands endure today, people love them. And perhaps if you knew how to use it, the book was actually useful. Maybe not always in its recipes per se, but it did offer practical guidance in making the most of whatever was at hand. With advice like adding mayonnaise to your food is a great digestive aid, and advice on
1991年苏联解体后，饥饿和愤怒再次卷土重来。许多人失去了所有财产。对许多人来说，这些食物唤起了那个可怕时代的怀旧情绪。这些苏联食品品牌延续至今，人们依然喜爱它们。也许只要你知道如何使用它，这本书其实是很有用的。也许并不总是体现在它的食谱本身，但它确实在如何充分利用手头仅有的东西方面提供了实用的指导。比如增加蛋黄酱作为绝佳助消化剂的建议，以及教你如何
how to portion out meals so it looks like there's a lot on your plate. It did help cooks adapt to the occasional lack of even the most basic produce. [♪ Music playing in background, playing in background, Babushka, Mark and I finally sat down to eat the Bliné. Okay, so Babushka, what do you think of the bline? I don't know. Be honest. Yeah.
分配饭菜分量，让盘子看起来满满当当的建议。它确实帮助厨师们适应了偶尔连最基本的农产品都短缺的困境。[♪ 背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，巴布什卡、马克和我终于坐下来吃布利尼薄饼。好吧，巴布什卡，你觉得这个布利尼怎么样？我不知道。说实话。对。
Sorry, no. Sorry, no, it's not, it's not a bline. It's a little embarrassing. The bline is far too thick and yeasty, but we eat it anyway with sour cream and smoked salmon and dill. At the table, Babushka looks at the spread and says, you know, the book also tells you
抱歉，不。抱歉，不，这不是，这不是布利尼。这有点尴尬。这个布利尼太厚而且发酵味太重了，但我们还是配着酸奶油、熏三文鱼和莳萝把它吃完了。在餐桌旁，巴布什卡看着这一桌食物说道：“你知道吗，书里还告诉你……”
how to properly set a table. Oh yeah, I say, are we doing it right? She shakes her head. Any cookbook has the potential to shape a person's diet or habits or sit on a shelf unused. And the same can be said about this one. But one thing is clear, whether you loved it or hated it or just let it sit on your shelf, over time, the book became uniquely and authentically Russian. Or at least Russian enough, that despite all its flaws when Babushka finally left the Soviet Union, she loved it with her, this thing that was produced by the state she was fleeing.
如何正确摆放餐桌。哦，是的，我说，我们做对了吗？她摇了摇头。任何一本食谱都有可能重塑一个人的饮食或习惯，或者在书架上吃灰。这本书也是如此。但有一点是明确的，无论你爱它、恨它，还是任由它在书架上吃灰，随着时间的推移，这本书变得具有独特而真实的俄罗斯特色。或者至少足够具有俄罗斯特色，以至于尽管它有种种缺陷，当巴布什卡最终离开苏联时，她依然把它带在身边，这件由她正要逃离的国家生产的东西。
And when she got to San Francisco, she unpacked her boxes, pulled this book out, and stood it up on a shelf. Years later, she dusted it off, and handed it to me. An intriguing look inside the Soviet communal kitchen with the kitchen sisters. Now for this. Lasha's exploration of the official Soviet cookbook reminded me of an amazing piece by the kitchen sisters from 2014 about the communal kitchens that were also part of Stalin's plans for re-imagining the culture of food post-revolution. It is a favorite of mine. Enjoy.
当她到达旧金山时，她打开箱子，把这本书拿出来，竖在书架上。多年后，她拂去上面的灰尘，把它交给了我。由Kitchen Sisters带来的引人入胜的苏联公社厨房内部探秘。接下来是这个。拉沙对官方苏联食谱的探索让我想起了Kitchen Sisters在2014年制作的一部精彩作品，关于公社厨房，这也是斯大林重新构想革命后饮食文化计划的一部分。这是我的最爱之一。尽情享受吧。
revolution. The Stalin time, the theoretical idea of the communism declared that all people have to be equal, and the women have to be freed from slavery work in the kitchen. It mustn't be kitchen in the apartment, it will go and eat in the cafeteria. I am Sergei Khrushchev, retired professor from Brown University. My father was Nikita Khrushchev, retired professor from Brown University. My father was Nikita Khrushchev, the head of the Soviet Union from 1953 to 1964. The most important part of kitchen politics in the early Soviet time and revolution time was they would like to have houses without kitchen. який має бути візовки кичин. Бо зі кичин є бурджуа. У цьому феміляє, якщо був кичин, був бурджуа,
革命。在斯大林时期，共产主义的理论构想宣布所有人都必须平等，妇女必须从厨房的奴隶劳动中解放出来。公寓里不应该有厨房，人们会去食堂吃饭。我是谢尔盖·赫鲁晓夫，布朗大学退休教授。我的父亲是尼基塔·赫鲁晓夫，布朗大学退休教授。我的父亲是尼基塔·赫鲁晓夫，1953年至1964年苏联领导人。早期苏联时期和革命时期厨房政治中最重要的一部分是，他们希望建造没有厨房的房屋。本应有厨房。因为厨房是资产阶级的。在这个家庭中，如果有厨房，就是资产阶级的，
і був бурджуа. Я елік Сандр Дженіс, Рашен Райтер, і Редюджурналіст. Зі відео відео, що був бурджуа. Бо зі кичин. journalists. The first houses that we built during the revolution, they were without kitchen. Everybody supposed to eat huge 500 people. Cafeteria contains. This is part of the romantic approach of the early post-revolutionary years. My name is Marsha Karab from Leningrad. I worked for the Russian Service of the BBC. People forget what an incredible abheaval the 1917 revolution was.
而且是资产阶级的。我是亚历山大·杰尼斯，俄罗斯作家兼电台记者。视频显示这是资产阶级的。因为厨房。记者。我们在革命期间建造的第一批房子是没有厨房的。每个人都应该在一个巨大的、可容纳500人的食堂里吃饭。食堂包含。这是早期革命后几年浪漫主义方法的一部分。我叫玛莎·卡拉布，来自列宁格勒。我曾为英国广播公司（BBC）俄罗斯语部工作。人们忘记了1917年革命是一场多么不可思议的剧变。
There was a huge movement to free the country from the Zaris. Bring happiness to poorer classes. People thought maybe it's a good idea to relieve a housewife from her daily chores so that she could develop as a personality she would go and play the piano, write poetry and she wouldn't cook and wash up. The idea to have cafeterias was the continuation of this wonderful intention. on the full intention. But it was only in theory because after the revolution began the civil war and they didn't build any cafeterias. Bolsheviks were not in the food.
当时有一场巨大的运动，旨在将国家从沙皇手中解放出来。为贫苦阶层带来幸福。人们认为，把家庭主妇从日常杂务中解脱出来也许是个好主意，这样她就能作为一个人格独立发展，她可以去弹钢琴、写诗，而不用做饭和洗碗。拥有食堂的想法是这一美好初衷的延续。但这也只是理论上的，因为革命爆发后接着就是内战，他们根本没有建造任何食堂。布尔什维克并不热衷于食物。
Lenin was not a foodie. They saw it, it was fuel to feed the workers. Bolsheviks kind of wanted to eradicate privacy and private hearts, private stove, becomes very politicized. I'm Ania von Bremsen. I'm the author of Mastering the Art of Soviet Cooking. Food shortages and the famine of the 1920s devastated whatever was left with the Russian
列宁不是一个美食家。在他们看来，食物只是喂养工人的燃料。布尔什维克有点想要根除隐私和私人炉灶，私人炉灶变得高度政治化。我是安妮亚·冯·布伦森。我是《掌握苏联烹饪艺术》的作者。20th世纪20年代的食物短缺和饥荒摧毁了俄罗斯残存的一切
kitchen. My name is Grisha Freyden, professor of Russian literature at Stanford University. Stalin's industrialization program included the industrialization of food, completely new food appeared, mass produced the whole of the Soviet Union in all 120 different ethnic groups, were suddenly being fed exactly the same stuff. Choices for this or that food, the tastings, took place at the plebeburo level. The kinds of candies that began to be mass produced was decided on a special meeting with Stalin, Molotov.
厨房。我叫格里沙·弗赖登，斯坦福大学俄罗斯文学教授。斯大林的工业化计划包括食物的工业化，完全崭新的食物出现了，整个苏联大规模生产，所有120个不同的民族突然被喂养完全相同的东西。对这种或那种食物的选择和品尝是在政治局层面进行的。开始大规模生产什么样的糖果，是在与斯大林、莫洛托夫的特别会议上决定的。
One of the goals of the new Soviet government was to provide housing to the workers. I'm Edward Chandravich, venture investor. I'm also Russian poet. They started putting people into communal apartments before they were generally occupied by a Russian rich or aristocrats who were driven out by the new government. I lived in the communal apartment till the age of 16 about 10 families sharing one kitchen. On one side of my room was the man who washed corpses
新苏联政府的目标之一是为工人提供住房。我是爱德华·钱德拉维奇，风险投资家。我同时也是一名俄罗斯诗人。他们开始把人们塞进公社公寓，这些公寓以前通常由被新政府赶出的俄罗斯富豪或贵族占据。我住在公社公寓直到16岁，大约10个家庭共用一个厨房。我房间的一边是一个清洗尸体的人
at the local morgue. There were two rooms where a mother and father served in the KGB. Then there was a woman whose husband was serving a sentence for stealing bread from the bread factory where he worked. There were two four burner stoves. Everybody cooked their own.
在当地的太平间。有两间房住着克格勃的一位母亲和父亲。然后是一位妇女，她的丈夫因从工作的面包厂偷面包正在服刑。有两个四个火眼的炉灶。每个人都做自己的。
Cabbage soup, washed with meats, potatoes, buckwheat, roots, five different cats. Well, chicken, five different pots that are all marked when the relations between the neighbors were especially fierce. You could see locks on the cabinets. People cooked in the kitchen, but they practically never ate there. They would go with their pots along the corridor to their rooms and eat there. Because there were communal kitchens, they were not places where you would bring your friends. I think that was one of the ideas for creating communal kitchen. It would be in watchful eye of society over every communal apartment.
卷心菜汤，洗过的肉，土豆，荞麦，根茎，五种不同的猫。好吧，鸡肉，五个标有记号的不同锅，当邻居之间的关系特别紧张时。你可以看到橱柜上有锁。人们在厨房做饭，但他们几乎从不在那里吃饭。他们会拿着锅沿着走廊回到自己的房间去吃。因为那是公社厨房，它们不是你可以带朋友去的地方。我认为这是创建公社厨房的初衷之一。它将置于社会对每个公社公寓的密切监视之下。
People would report in each other. You would never know who would be reporting. So even though you lived in a communal apartment in a horrible hovel and had very little to eat, there were moments when you could glimpse the future. After Stalin's death, the goal of the Soviet Union was to catch up and overtake the United States. Vice President Nixon escorts Soviet Premier Kuschev on a preview of the United States fair as Skolniky Park in Moscow. Kuschev decided to have an exchange of exhibitions with the United States, in order to compete with the West, you had to know what it was. This was 1959. I was 13 years old.
人们会互相告发。你永远不知道谁会去告发。所以，尽管你住在公社公寓的一个可怕的窝棚里，吃得很少，但有时你还是能窥见未来。斯大林死后，苏联的目标是赶超美国。副总统尼克松陪同苏联总理赫鲁晓夫参观莫斯科索科利尼基公园的美国展览预展。赫鲁晓夫决定与美国进行展览交流，为了与西方竞争，你必须了解它是什么。那是1959年。我当时13岁。
Every visitor would pass the counter where Pepsi Cola was given out in disposable paper cups that I had never seen before. They were the first American company, even before McDonald's, to get their foot in the door. Stalin's Russian vodka. Part of the deal between Pepsi Cola and the Soviet Union was that the Pepsi Cola would be given the distribution rights for Stoli, Stolichna vodka. The kitchen at the American exhibition reflected itself on the conversation between Khrushchev and Nixon, known as the Kitchen Debate.
每个参观者都会经过一个柜台，那里用我以前从未见过的一次性纸杯分发百事可乐。他们是第一家进入市场的美国公司，甚至比麦当劳还要早。斯大林的俄罗斯伏特加。百事可乐与苏联协议的一部分是，百事可乐将获得苏联红牌伏特加（Stolichnaya）的经销权。美国展览中的厨房反映在赫鲁晓夫和尼克松之间的对话中，被称为“厨房辩论”。
American built the model of the American Kitchen. And then they go to this kitchen. Nixon talked about American achievement. My father talked about Soviet achievement. They argue with each other which system is better. Nixon, a crosshove, talked about food. How people live. How people leave. How people eat. Communal kitchens was produced by the kitchen sisters with Charles Maid's, Nathan Dalton and Brandy Howe, mixed by Jim McKee.
美国人建造了美国厨房的模型。然后他们走到这个厨房里。尼克松谈论了美国的成就。我父亲谈论了苏联成就。他们争论哪个系统更好。尼克松和赫鲁晓夫谈论食物。人们如何生活。人们如何离开。人们如何吃。公社厨房由Kitchen Sisters与Charles Maid's、Nathan Dalton和Brandy Howe制作，由Jim McKee混音。
It was produced as part of the kitchen sisters' hidden kitchen series heard on NPR, supported by the National Endowment for the Arts and the National Endowment for the Humanities. There are Russian recipes from old communal kitchens to be found and a link to their amazing unmeasible podcast at kitchensisters.org. 99% of visible was produced this week by La Shima Dawn and edited by Christopher Johnson and Joe Rosenberg, mixed in tech production by Amida Ganatra, music by a director of sound Sean Rial. Delaney Hall is the executive producer Kurt Colstady is the digital director, Liz Boyd
它是作为Kitchen Sisters在NPR上播出的“隐藏厨房”系列的一部分制作的，由美国国家艺术基金会和美国国家人文基金会资助。在kitchensisters.org上可以找到来自老公社厨房的俄罗斯食谱以及指向他们令人惊叹的不可思议播客的链接。本周99%可见是由La Shima Dawn制作，Christopher Johnson和Joe Rosenberg编辑，技术制作由Amida Ganatra混音，配乐由声音总监Sean Rial负责。Delaney Hall是执行制片人，Kurt Colstady是数字总监，Liz Boyd
at the fact-checking Max Kri-Scheyev help with translation. Thrust the team includes Emmet Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh, Chris Barubey, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Thanks today to Edward Geist, Dara Goldstein, Anna Harzeyevna, Pavel Sudkin, and Anya von Bremsen. Anya's book, mastering the art of Soviet cooking, is a must read and look out for her forthcoming book on food and nationalism. Lastly, a very special thank you to Mark Lipkin, Maria LeKinna, and most of all, to Babushka. We are a part of the Stitcher and Serious
在事实核查方面，Max Kri-Scheyev协助了翻译。信任团队包括Emmet Fitzgerald、Vivian Leigh、Chris Barubey、Sophia Klatsker以及我Roman Mars。今天感谢Edward Geist、Dara Goldstein、Anna Harzeyevna、Paul Sudkin和Anya von Bremsen。Anya的书《掌握苏联烹饪艺术》是必读之作，请期待她即将出版关于食物和民族主义的新书。最后，非常感谢Mark Lipkin、Maria LeKinna，最重要的是，感谢巴布什卡。我们是Stitcher和Serious
XM Podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, quartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars on the show at 99pi work or on Instagram and read it too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99pi at 99po.org. Doot stitcher. Doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot do There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
XM播客家族的一部分。现在总部位于美丽的、上城奥克兰潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。在美丽的、上城奥克兰潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。您可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与有关该程序的讨论。您可以在Twitter上@Roman Mars，或在节目@99pi work或Instagram和Reddit上找到我。您可以在99po.org上找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接以及99pi的每一期往期节目。Doot stitcher. Doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot doot 本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。